holiday overall South Korea has done
five times more tests than the US per
capita why is that I don't think that's
true that is true and you said this
morning the White House said the u.s.
passes South Carolina virus testing who
are you with
Yahoo News and it's not true per capita
you want to respond to that if you have
the numbers so remember early on we push
tests to the outbreak areas just like he
described his primary outbreak was in
Miami Dade and Broward County and Palm
Beach so they pushed tests into that
region we did the same thing in the
United States so if you look at every
single state that had an outbreak their
testing is greater than anywhere in the
world they're in the four per you know
42 per thousand raise your point is
taken about individual areas but overall
we've had 14 times more infections than
South Korea so are we doing something
wrong and why is that they have a very
dense population yeah our epidemic looks
much more like the European epidemic so
right now we're tracking very close to
the countries in Europe and we're
testing at their rate of their
concentrated epidemics and where they're
occurring in the Metro so I think it
really shows the susceptibility of our
major cities in the same way they were
susceptible in Europe and so we've been
very focused on that that's not the same
we're very much supporting the rural
states and very much supporting their
testing there's no there's no state
right now in the United States that's
tested really less than 1% which is
pretty remarkable when they don't really
have significant cases gentlemen I just
want to make it clear that um South
Korea's testing was 11 per per a hundred
thousand and we're at 17 per hundred are
you know apologize yeah that's why you
go ahead with your numbers I've seen
this way nobody knows who you are
including me
mr. bridges just checking again you
ought to get your facts right people but
we have had the other where your facts
are wrong